Let's go next to our caller from the eight
five zero area code.
Who's calling today from eight five zero?
Hi, David.
Look, Luke.
What can I do for you?
My questions about Bill Clinton's speech last
night from the Democratic National Convention.
Yes, a couple nights ago.
Because this is Friday, remember?
Oh, gotcha.
Yeah.
I was wondering what you thought about the
lighting of the room.
You know, the lighting was amazing, actually.
I mentioned this during the lives.
It was some of the most pristine lighting
that I've seen.
And it almost looked green screen like they
got it wasn't head on right.
One side of his face was just just softly
brighter than the other side.
It had depth.
It had size.
I mean, it was you know, the gaffers and the
grips deserve a round of congratulations.
Bill Light.
Bill Clinton lighting was amazing.
Awesome.
A quick question and a comment, so if you
don't mind.
Sure.
OK.
I was turned off to politics and the whole
Merrick Garland thing happened in the last
year of Obama's presidency.
Right.
And I was thrown back in once with the rise
of Trump, like it's even surreal to this day.
So I've been looking for sort of political
commentators who are well reasoned in their
arguments.
They're not tied down to like tribalism or
anything like that.
Very fair and reasonable political commentators.
OK.
Lean left personally, but that's what I'm
looking for.
Your appearances on the Joe Rogan podcast
brought me to you.
And I was wondering if you can recommend anyone
who sort of meets that criteria that you do
this sort of well reasoned, eloquent political
commentators.
I've been recently put on a good name as a
destiny.
Oh, you mean that?
You mean Stephen.
Kenneth Destiny.
Bernell the second.
There we go.
But him, you.
Is there anyone else who can recommend some
fairly new to your show and your YouTube channel,
stuff like that?
You know, it's really just me.
I can't I can really just recommend more of
my own show.
Unfortunately, I could.
I wouldn't.
No, I mean, listen, here's the thing.
To be honest, I'm the wrong person to ask
because I don't even I barely know who's out
there.
Like, there's a bunch of people who are my
friends who do this stuff.
But I'm actually I was talking to Lands of
the Cerf's recently.
He knows the landscape of the commentators
on left and right.
So we're thinking of doing a collaboration
soon where he's sort of going to expose me
to the good and bad, including the underbelly
of of right wing commentary and stuff like
that.
I really would not be able to say there's
so many people out there now doing their thing,
but I just don't do any watching of content
like mine as a personal.
I just get enough of this stuff where I want
to disconnect and I don't.
I watch, you know, chest's gardening instruction
on you do.
I just really don't know.
I don't know.
Awesome.
Well, thanks anyway.
But just one last comment, if you don't mind.
Yeah.
Are your appearances on the.
I think his name is just Lee Peterson.
Yes.
That's got to be the funniest stuff I've ever
seen in my life.
Thank you.
I would some day after the pandemic, hopefully
I can be back on with him.
There would be incredible.
Thanks for taking my call, David.
All right, my friend.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Great to hear from Luke there.
That is going to do it for calls today.
Much better sound today during the calls.
We will take calls again.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot.com.